In 1974, Petros was 16, living peacefully
in his Cyprus village
with his farming family.
Today, he's in his 60s and still can't go
home, because there's a military buffer
zone with soldiers and
barbed wire blocking his path.
Petros is one of over 210,000 people who
lost their homes when Cyprus was divided.
Greek families fled south, Turkish
families fled north.
50 years later, their children and
grandchildren are still separated by
Europe's last divided capital.
This isn't just a sad family story.
This division is blocking billions in
energy development,
energy development, creating tensions
creating tensions within NATO,
within NATO, and it
and it didn't happen by accident.
So how did an island of neighbors become
So, how did an island of neighbors become
a militarized border that still affects
global politics today?
Before 1974, Greeks and Turks lived side
by side on this
strategically vital island.
They were neighbors, business
partners, sometimes friends.
But by 1963, politics
turned them into enemies.
Turkish Cypriots were forced into
isolated enclaves, surrounded communities
like West Berlin during the Cold War.
For 11 years, they lived under what the
UN called "virtual imprisonment".
Meanwhile, Greek Cypriots controlled most
of the island, but lived in fear of
escalating violence.
Both communities suffered attacks,
displacement and the
constant threat of wars to come.
Imagine your neighborhood surrounded by
hostile checkpoints for over a decade.
That was reality for
both communities by 1974.
By 1974, Greek extremists had a plan.
Unite Cyprus with Greece and eliminate
the Turkish population.
In a 1976 interview, Cyprus president
Makarios claimed that Greek military
leader Dimitrios Ioannidis
had told him to attack Turkish Cypriots
suddenly everywhere on the island and
eliminate them to the last one.
Makarios said he refused, but in July
1974, these extremists staged a coup,
installing Nicos Sampson, a man with a
documented history of
killing Turkish civilians.
Turkey invaded on July 20th
to protect Turkish enclaves.
Initially limited, arguably legal under
international treaty.
But three weeks later, Turkey launched a
massive second operation,
seizing 37% of the island.
This expansion killed over 120 Greek
Cypriot civilians in villages like
Maratha and Santalaris.
Both communities became
victims of extremist violence.
But here's what neither side tells you.
A third player was pulling
strings behind the scenes.
According to historian William Malinson's
analysis of declassified
State Department cables,
the CIA warned Henry Kissinger on June
29, 1974, that Greek coup
preparations were underway.
Malinson argues that America
chose not to prevent the crisis,
Seeing strategic advantage in Cyprus's
seeing strategic advantage in Cyprus's
division during the Cold War.
division during the Cold War, a unified
A unified Cyprus might align with the
Soviet Union, but a divided Cyprus would
keep both halves
dependent on Western protection.
Consider this, if you knew your neighbors
Consider this. If you knew your neighbors
were about to start
shooting, would you try to stop it?
Or would you let it happen because it
served your interests?
Over 210,000 people
lost their homes in weeks.
162,000 Greek Cypriots fled their
ancestral villages in the north.
Farmers leaving olive groves their
families had tended to for generations.
Shop owners abandoning
businesses built over lifetimes.
50,000 Turkish Cypriots headed north,
leaving behind homes in the
south, they'd never see again.
You're a parent in 1974, extremists
You're a parent in 1974. Extremists
control your government.
Foreign troops are landing,
Foreign troops are landing.
you have two hours to pack.
You have two hours to pack.
What do you take?
What do you leave behind?
2001 people vanished during the violence.
1,508 Greek Cypriots
and 493 Turkish Cypriots.
The UN has identified 766
bodies from mass graves.
Over 1,200 families are still waiting to
learn what happened to their loved ones.
For Greek Cypriots the
For Greek Cypriots, the
losses went beyond homes.
Ancient Orthodox churches in the north
were abandoned or destroyed.
Entire villages like Varosha became ghost
towns sealed off for 50 years.
According to the University of Cyprus,
Greek Cypriot property in the north is
worth over 82 billion today.
Land, homes and businesses that families
built over centuries, now inaccessible
across a military line.
Imagine if half your city was suddenly
off limits and you could see your
childhood home from a
distance but never visited.
Greek Cypriots and most of the
international community see
this as a illegal occupation.
UN resolution 541 declared northern
Cyprus legally invalid.
The European court ruled Turkey violated
The European Court ruled Turkey violated
multiple articles of international law
and owes billions in compensation.
Turkish Cypriots counter that they faced
systematic persecution and
credible genocide threats.
They see international isolation as
punishment for surviving.
The 1960 treaty gave Turkey guarantor
rights and they argue they still need
protection from
potential future violence.
These legal arguments matter because
Cyprus sits on massive energy wealth.
In 2011 the Aphrodite gas field discovery
In 2011, the Aphrodite gas field
discovery revealed reserves that could
power Europe for years.
But the division means that these
resources can be fully developed.
Cyprus has signed deals with Egypt and
Israel to build pipelines.
But Turkey blocks drilling ships claiming
But Turkey blocks drilling ships,
Turkish Cypriots deserve equal access to
claiming Turkish Cypriots deserve equal
access to any energy revenues.
So who's right? The answer could affect
energy prices across Europe.
The tensions are escalating. Turkish
warships now regularly escort drilling
vessels into waters Cyprus considers its
exclusive economic zone.
Greece threatens military response to
protect Cyprus' rights.
The EU has imposed sanctions on Turkish
officials involved in
drilling operations.
These are all NATO allies.
Greece, Turkey and Cyprus as an EU member
Greece, Turkey and Cyprus as an EU
member, potentially confronting each
other over resources that could benefit
everyone if they
could agree to share them.
Meanwhile, the island's legal complexity
has made it a haven for
questionable financial flows.
European Parliament investigations
revealed that Cyprus' investment programs
attracted over 200
billion in Russian money,
Much of it from oligarchs now under
much of it from oligarchs now under
sanctions for supporting
Putin's war in Ukraine.
The division creates regulatory gaps that
sophisticated money
launderers can exploit,
turning Cyprus' tragedy into a tool for
avoiding international sanctions.
But there's hope. Young Cypriots see
But there's hope. Young
Cypriots see division as absurd.
division as absurd. They cross the buffer
zone to study, work, even fall in love.
They cross the buffer zone to study,
work, even fall in love.
Opinion polls show majorities on both
sides support reunification, with
property rights, security guarantees and
political equality for both communities.
Remember Petros from Zodea village? He
Remember Petros from Zodea village?
spent 50 years unable to visit the
He spent 50 years unable to visit the
orchard his family
tended to for generations.
At his age, he
probably never will return.
But young Turkish and Greek Cypriots are
crossing that buffer zone to build
friendships their parents never could.
The question isn't whether Petros will
see his village again.
It's whether his grandchildren will
inherit another 50 years of division,
Or whether leaders will finally choose
or whether leaders will finally choose
compromise over conflict.
Looking at this 50 year conflict, what do
Looking at this 50-year conflict, what do
you think matters more?
Following international law
Following international law or protecting
people's safety, both communities have
legitimate fears based on
real violence they suffered.
Let me know your thoughts.
And if this story surprised you, imagine
what other ancient ethnic conflicts are
actually shaped by modern power politics.
I'll fact check whatever you suggest.
I'll fact-check whatever you suggest.